es geht mir um die masten geflecht im
moment gilt ja noch und im moment gilt
die auch hier im gebäude
wenn wir nicht gerade ein interview
führen und sie gilt auch in öffentlichen
verkehrsmitteln
wann wird die wieder ausgesetzt sie ist
ja nicht befristet das kann ich ihnen
sagen dann wenn es soweit ist
warum weil ich ihnen nicht sagen kann
doch nicht abschließend jetzt
versprechen können wir die pandemie
läuft wissen sie ich finde wir haben in
deutschland etwas vergleichsweise klüger
gemacht als vielleicht in manchen
anderen ländern
wir haben nicht mit daten gearbeitet
sondern mit instanzen ich finde dass
also zu sagen also bei einem bestimmten
datum werden bestimmte lockerungen
weggenommen ohne zu wissen wie ist denn
dann das infektionsgeschehen als noch
eine mutation gegeben ist sonst noch
irgendetwas passiert ist die
intensivstation voll
ich arbeite nicht mit daten ich arbeite
mit der jeweiligen infektions lager über
wir haben kein da wünsch ich mir nichts
mehr als das was sie sich wahrscheinlich
auch wünschen dass wir irgendwann auf
maske und abstand und hygiene werden
verzichten können ich bin auch sehr
sicher das werden wir können aber ich
kann ihnen noch nicht das datum dass sie
können es im gegensatz zu mir mit
entscheiden und deswegen interessiert
mich auch gar kein datum sondern mich
interessiert die bedingung die erfüllt
sein muss die voraussetzungen die
erfüllt sein muss damit wir die massen
flächen ablegen können ist das definiert
dann wenn jeder sich morgen am tag
problemlos impfen lassen könnte weil
genug impfstoff für alle da ist ist für
mich definitiv ein zeitpunkt das haben
sie eben für den sommer dann sehen einem
jahr wieder maßnahmen zurücknehmen wird
können ob schon alle maßnahmen also ich
finde halt sehr wichtig dass wir das was
wir erreicht haben jetzt nicht einfach
in so einem alter wollen möglichst alles
wieder wie vorher
und im moment kommt auf seite eins wäre
das verspricht im sommer ist alles
wieder wie vorher aber es bringt ja
nichts
wichtig ist doch dass wir diesen zustand
den wir uns jetzt erkämpft haben halten
nämlich dass wir lockern können dass wir
eine bessere perspektive haben dass wir
rauskommen aus dieser pandemie und wir
werden das zug um zug erreichen
auch dass wir keine maske wer tragen ein
ganz wichtiger punkt dafür ist dass
jeder in impfangebot hut bekommen können
dann bin ich sicher werden die
allermeisten regeln schon fallen
mehr nachrichten und breaking news nur
bei bild schau dich hier das nächste
video an und vergiss nicht zu abonnieren